okay UN Security Council has voted to
extend humanitarian aid deliveries to
millions of Syrians who rely on it to
survive they canceled backed a proposal
that would use only one authorized
crossing point for aid supplies into the
country that being on the turkey-syria
border aid agencies are warning that the
decision to shut down all other access
routes will intensify the suffering of
thousands of displaced Syrians and cost
lives the result of the voting is as
follows twelve votes in favor no votes
against and three abstentions the
resolution submitted by Belgium and
Germany is adopted a resolution from the
United Nations Security Council to
resume aid deliveries to war-torn Syria
one day after the program had expired
but it gave way to Russia's unyielding
demands of the two functioning ones only
one border crossing from Turkey will
remain open for the next 12 months a
move that will cut a lifeline as Western
countries describe it for Syrians in the
country's Northwest Western countries
had even pushed to reopen a border
crossing from Iraq to be clear today's
resolution leaves us bitterly
disappointed at the loss of baba solemn
and oli our BIA border crossings the
Syrian themselves if they had a voice
would tell you that the loss of those
crossings is unacceptable and risk the
health and welfare of millions of their
fellow Syrians how those people who gave
the instructions to gave the
instructions to cut off the aid of
500,000 children if they are ready to
look into the mirror tomorrow the
Security Council was in a deadlock the
majority of members argued that two
crossing points were essential
especially during the corona virus
pandemic but the veto powers Russia and
China argued that the northwest of Syria
can be reached from within the country
we could have arrived to these
result much earlier and one most
important body crossing to eat lib is
what Russia was proposing since the very
beginning
initially the UN ate mission had
included access to Syria from Jordan and
Iraq those crossing points were cuts in
January also due to Russia and China OTW
correspondent pasul LED in is in Beirut
and has more on that story for us Basso
it's clearly the point of contention so
why did Russia and China only want this
one
border crossing I don't know it seems
that the Russians are pushing forward or
the Russian intentions in the future to
pass these hearing aid through the
Syrian government only according to some
sources close to the Russian position
told me this morning that the Russians
prefer to move or to pass this he
matheran aid via the Turkish border
rather than the Iraqi or Jordanian
borders as it used to be because these
supplies these aid will pass through
areas controlled by US army organs Allah
is at least why in Turkey even it's a
NATO ally member but at least the
Russian and the Turkish they have really
good position and good the good
conversation and good relations between
each other while we understand but at
the same time according to these sources
that some of according to a previous
experiences some of these aids and
mainly in Aleppo direct control and
stock by some rebels and refused to
deliver to the civilians for Turkey and
the same on the second hand for Turkey
this is why it's a profit its benefits
in Syria because it will keep Turkey in
control over ad lib and all its rebels
in that area so parcel in the end the
nations did in fact vote to extend aid
to the Syrian people so why is the
German UN Ambassador and others so
disappointed about this compromise
Anthony we can't talk here about two
main reasons first of all Germany and
Belgium were seeking to have two border
crossings one very Turkish borders of
course want to ad-lib and
again to Aleppo the compromise with the
Russia with the Security Council members
due to the Russian vetoes reached for
one border crossing to ad-lib directly
for six for one year instead of six
month
the second reason that Germany and
Belgium fear that some of these supplies
will not reach all the civilians in the
trip which they are in need to so what
else will this decision mean for the
people on the ground the situation on
the ground it's so dramatic we can say
according to opposition sources I'm
talking about the Syrian Observatory for
Human Rights told me this morning that
one border crossing will not be
sufficient but not be enough to stop to
supply 3 million people in Italy
especially that the medical situation
after the announcement of the first
Cabot 19 case in adlet the logistical
logistical and social circumstances
ended lip it's so dramatic so they fear
that these supplies through one body
person will not be sufficient to these 3
million people and on the other hand the
Observatory asked who will control this
border is a turkey or under the UN
control passes are edn by bird thank you
very much thank you